won't be until mid decade I don't think
until the economy can fully adjust and
we get those jobs back through the math
and it's not hard to get to 20%
unemployment the administration has bet
so much on PPP helping lead to what
they're saying will be likely a v-shaped
recovery and that doesn't seem very
certain at all it was obvious that many
on the Left were just giddy a couple
months ago that the virus had devastated
the booming Trump economy they were
thrilled and they were wish casting
gruesome jobs numbers from April April
basically all the way to Election Day
and they predicted that the economy
would shed another 8 million jobs in May
oh it was their hate in their anger
toward this administration that
continued to consume whatever good
judgment her since they have and today
the credibility of all those who
forecasted doom and gloom well it took a
major body blow when the stunning May
jobs numbers came in new jobs numbers
showed that the u.s. added two and a
half million jobs in May added that's a
big surprise this number is higher than
I would have predicted shocking for all
the right reasons to say this number
there's definitely underscoring the fact
that this will have been the shortest
recession in history remember there was
gonna be no v-shaped recovery well the
number of jobs created in the last month
by American entrepreneurs and businesses
shattered every record the Dow jumped
800 points today and the media was so
ready to pounce on what they presume
were going to be these horrid jobs
numbers that they were caught totally
off-guard now this morning the Amazon
Washington Post tweeted this Jim grim
milestone to be reached as May
unemployment rate nears 20%
well they deleted that embarrassment and
their second attempt read US jobless
rate unexpectedly declined to 13.3% in
May amid pandemic these are the most
dishonest people ever just to own up to
it
okay you did test Trump so much the
you allowed your own bias to get in the
way of what should be reporting and real
data analysis stock market was over
27-thousand today kids on Election Day
in 2016 it was at 18,000 so an honest
tweet who would have been maybe I don't
know in stunning jobs report investors
prefer Trump in a pandemic over the
Democrats on the verge of victory oh I
should have sent that one now just over
a week ago remember this the Politico
reported that Democrats are quote
dreading a full-blown recovery ahead of
November according to the article the
possibility of Americans getting back to
work has caused some Democrats
especially Obama alum alumni around
Washington to panic oh they're panicking
today well Joe Biden would surely have
preferred that we stayed in lockdown
through the election maybe all in
Michigan will for all I know and he
offered this feeble response to the
stunning economic news the president who
takes no responsibility for costing
millions and millions of Americans their
jobs does there's no credit when a
fraction of them return of course if Joe
wins the presidency we won't be seeing
these types of numbers because he'll
immediately make it easier to ship more
jobs over to China like we used to do
and he'll greenlight more foreign labor
to take the jobs that Americans would do
but what about the polls I know all of
you are freaking about the polls well
the experts say that Biden's way ahead
it's his election to lose folks like
James Carville are predicting a Democrat
wipeout experts say Americans want more
progressive government well they said
that in 2016 to remember all the same
people made all the same predictions but
then as now most of the so-called
experts are just horribly wrong in fact
they're not really experts in anything
I've concluded the media figures who
furrow their brows and huff and puff
about the president at every turn
so every tweet although left-wing
economist the social scientists are
desperate to usher in their era of a new
normal
they've been predicting Trump's imminent
political demise since day one their
predictions about Russia and Muller
wrong their predictions about
impeachment wrong their prediction about
Trump's China tariffs oh yeah wrong
their predictions about the USMC a wrong
their predictions about the coronavirus
wrong some of their predictions about
the Spring Break Ovid
super spreaders wrong and as I've said
time and again you with your common
sense are so much smarter than most of
these people will ever be again they're
not really experts they're just people
who go on TV to play the role of experts
yeah let's be very clear they're not
just getting it wrong time and again if
if that was all it was you know they
wouldn't have job anymore they're
important because they're perpetrating a
fraud on you in America and in some
cases it's even costing lives like that
bogus hydroxychloroquine study that was
published in the prestigious medical
journal the lancet I mean that's just
collapse they had to retract the whole
study we're going to expose that later
in the hour with two of the original law
medicine cabinet members you don't want
to miss that but countries and hospitals
including in this country hospitals they
stopped allowing the use of that drug
based on false data how scary is that
and the experts by the way locked you
down for weeks and weeks in your home
some of you still lockdown based on
false kovin mortality projections you
couldn't go to your daughter's wedding
your son's baseball game your favorite
restaurant your kids couldn't go to
school you miss graduations and proms
and all these life experiences but the
moment there was an event or a protest
that they thought was important all
their rules were out the window
look at Michigan Governor Gretchen
Whitmer pritzker in Illinois the left is
always the same it's always the same you
will sacrifice but they they won't just
like with Obamacare climate change and
everything else the experts and academia
come on they've been urging us to do
things like what defund the police
they've been urging that for years and
they say it's going to lead to safer
communities more trust
we know that's a fraud it's gonna lead
to more suffering and more destruction
but not for the rich liberals who vote
for Biden or the hashtagging Hollywood
celebrity so the fortune 500 CEOs
they're not gonna be affected really by
a disbanded police force they have their
own private security guards and their
expensive security systems they can flee
in their private jets to any country
they want any time a day or night
everyone else they'll be just left with
a lot of bad expert advice and that's
the angle